la réalité derrière le discours corneau
assène c'est que les catastrophes
naturelles tu 100 fois moins de terriens
chaque année qui lie à 100 ans alors
même que la population a été multipliée
par bientôt 4 donc on nous prévoit plein
de catastrophe mais la réalité c'est que
la pollution de l'air s'est effondré à
paris le smog le so2 les suit ont été
divisés par 1000 depuis 1955
les métaux lourds dans l'air le plomb
dans l'air a été divisée par mille à
paris sur les 60 dernières années on
nous explique que la pollution de l'air
est de pire en pire alors qu'elle
s'améliore d'année en année depuis
maintenant 60 ans donc oui les
ayatollahs verts ont convaincu les
français et notamment les jeunes
français que la fin du monde est là en
réalité il y a beaucoup de domaine
écologique ou la situation s'améliore
l'eau est de meilleure qualité
l'alimentation n'a jamais été aussi cède
les intoxications alimentaires faisait
2000 morts chaque année en france en
1900 la pollution de l'air on l'a vu
s'effondrer la diversité s'améliore en
france avec une augmentation très rapide
du nombre de gros mammifères le nombre
d'ours en france a été multiplié par
trois et demi en quelques années le
nombre de loups est passé de 0 loup à
550 lots ce qui fait d'ailleurs que
certains écologistes comme josé bové
réclame qu'on ne tue la totalité des
loups français parce qu'ils trouvent que
la biodiversité ne doit n'est pas si
bonne que ça et le nombre de lynx en
france est passé de zéro à plusieurs
centaines depuis 1972
donc derrière le tableau apocalyptique
on a bien sûr des problèmes écologiques
qu'il faut régler rationnellement mais
on a une amélioration globale de la
situation écologique qui est
spectaculaire et qui est très positive
[Musique]